it's pretty clear by now that apple is
planning on bringing 5g to their iphone
12 lineup which they should reveal about
two months from now
and some rumors are even pointing to
apple giving you the ability to choose
between 4g
and a more expensive 5g version of the
two
non-pro iphone 12 models now no matter
if you'll truly get the option or not
there's still this question that you
need to answer for yourself
do i really need 5g so what i'm gonna do
in this video is discuss the real world
benefits that i noticed using a 5g phone
compared to my 4g iphone and i'm also
going to talk about what other people
think of 5g
and ultimately how much it should affect
your buying decision
first of all you need to understand that
not all 5g is the same
their sub 6 5g and millimeter wave 5g
but before i discuss the differences i
want to talk about the success
of two popular smartphone brands that
have recently switched to 5g
let's start with samsung and the galaxy
s20 line
ever since they launched the s20 lineup
it's been rumored that sales of
samsung's s20 phones
were way down compared to last year's
galaxy s10
which shipments dropping by 32.6 percent
now of course we should definitely blame
some of that on the pandemic for the low
sales
since the entire smartphone industry
went down but
one thing is for certain the addition of
5g
made the s20 line very expensive at a
thousand dollars for the
entry level model so android authority
ran a poll
asking people why they didn't upgrade to
the s20
and about 71 of the people said that it
was just
too expensive and then the other 11
said that they don't need 5g and that
basically means that the addition of 5g
just wasn't worth the extra price for
all of those people
and to further prove the point it's been
rumored that samsung is
exercising caution on the note 20 parts
to try to keep the price down
there was even a mention that this was
specifically for the galaxy
note 20 5g model since 5g makes it
much more expensive now the oneplus 8
pro had a ton of hype thanks to the
exciting leaks
and the success of the previous oneplus
7 pro but there were a lot of people
that were disappointed by the high price
about a week before launch 9 to 5 google
made a poll asking users
how much would they be willing to spend
on the oneplus 8 pro
and almost half of them said 700
the price turned out to be from 900 to a
thousand dollars which only about
10 said that they are willing to pay
according to the poll
and of course the high price was mostly
attributed to the addition of 5g
so the point that i'm trying to make is
that 5g is causing phones to get much
more
expensive than people expect and there
are now rumors pointing to the iphone 12
being priced at least 50
more expensive than the iphone 11 prices
despite
not having ear pods or a charger in the
box
so now the question is if apple does
give you the choice of getting a 5g
model
should you pay the extra price i've been
using apple's iphone 11 pro max for
almost a full year now
which obviously uses 4g so i'm gonna
give you guys my experience
of this iphone compared to the galaxy
s20 ultra
which is the most expensive mainstream
5g
phone i currently use t-mobile here in
spokane washington
and 4g has mostly worked fine for me for
everything from web browsing to using
apps
i've really only noticed a couple of
issues with connectivity
the main issue i've noticed so far is
occasional hiccups when i'm trying to
stream youtube videos
there's also the fact that i start to
lose service going further away from the
city
and sometimes in certain dead zones of
the city other than that the only other
issue
is that reception isn't that great when
i'm inside of larger buildings like my
church
or target for example now let's talk
about my experience with 5g
a couple months ago i switched to the
galaxy s20 ultra so that i could give it
a proper review
and since i have t-mobile i don't have
access to the ultra fast
millimeter wave 5g in my city just the
sub 6 5g
that's because right now there are only
a small amount of cities that actually
have millimeter 5g towers
and to get the great speeds you actually
have to be
very close to those towers that's
because it works using
a very specific part of the radio
frequency spectrum
between 24 gigahertz and 100 gigahertz
which have a very short wavelength this
basically allows more bandwidth or data
to be transferred but the issue is that
it doesn't travel very far
and it doesn't penetrate walls well at
all and this is also a type of 5g which
is the most controversial
with many people concerned about the
health impacts of the shortwave radio
frequency
now sub 65g on the other hand has a lot
more in common with 4g
than it does with millimeter wave 5g for
example
t-mobile was able to upgrade their cell
towers to sub 6 relatively quickly and
easily
all across the us since it uses a much
longer
wavelength millimeter wave 5g requires a
lot more work
and a fiber optic internet connection
which is why it's taking so long to
implement it
so even though the galaxy s20 ultra
supports both sub 6 and millimeter wave
i only have access to t-mobile sub 6
here in spokane so here was
my experience with it it was fantastic
there were a few spots where i typically
had just one bar
and data was pretty much unusable and in
those cases
the s20 ultra with sub 65g would give me
two bars at times maybe even three and
it would work just fine
browsing the web was super snappy and i
could consistently play back youtube
videos at 1440p
with no buffering or hiccups keep in
mind my iphone had issues at times
even with 720p and i rarely tried
1080. on top of that in areas with a
good signal my data speeds were about
double the speed testing him at the same
location at the same time just pulling
the sim from one
and putting it into the other and during
congestion
up to six times faster as you guys could
see here
let me just say going back to my iphone
4g
was noticeable after the s20 ultra
most people probably won't get much use
out of that millimeter wave 5g
for at least a couple years so if you're
thinking about buying the pro model
iphone 12
just for that reason it probably doesn't
make sense
now sub six 5g is definitely worth it
since it gives you better reception
overall
faster speeds and it allowed me to
stream youtube without a hiccup
even at 1440p which was awesome now
in my opinion i still think apple needs
to add 5g to all of the phones this year
i don't think it makes sense to have
multiple versions of the phones at
different price points
now they could wait another year but
then they will be
really a ways behind the competition so
as long as apple can keep the price of
their phones the same
they should switch to 5g and be done
with it
and luckily most rumors are pointing to
the price staying very close
and that's probably because apple will
likely no longer be shipping earpods and
even a charger in the box
which in my opinion is a worthwhile
trade-off
realistically even if we don't need 5g
this year
most iphone users keep their phones for
3 years or more now
so it would be really nice to have it be
future proof
if so we could end up with another
iphone 6s
situation where it is so good that it
becomes the standard
long term for a lot of people if this
video is helpful
go ahead and tap that like button and
click the circle above to subscribe
and also be sure to check out our iphone
12 leaks and rumors video
right over there thank you guys for
watching and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
you